we begin joe biden he's breaking records
all across the board more americans are
now hospitalized with covert 19 than
ever before in this pandemic we have
illegal immigrants are crossing our
southern border at an unprecedented pace
fentanyl deaths in america are now
higher than ever economic optimism is at
an 18-month low the backlog of cargo
ships off the coast of california
waiting to dock and unload yeah that's
also at an all-time high and the price
of oil is surging nearing 85 dollars a
barrel with predictions it may go as
high as 125 dollars a barrel i guess
he's back begging opec and breaking
today inflation it is now the highest
rate
in 40 years four decades now november
november's inflation report was bad joe
told us it was going to get better they
also told us it was transitory now
they're backing off of that december was
worse now than november now every dollar
that you earn is worth seven percent
less than it was only one year ago today
according to two recent studies this
high rate of inflation is a massive tax
especially on the poor and middle class
in this country it is costing the
typical american family more than 5 000
plus dollars a year uh joe you're proud
of yourself that's your record do you
even know what's going on do you know
that today is wednesday anyway according
to joe or whoever writes his tweets this
is actually a good thing
okay
quote today's inflation numbers show a
meaningful reduction in headline
inflation over last month we're making
progress and slowing the rate of price
increases but there's still more work to
do i remain focused on lowering the cost
for families and maintaining strong
economic growth
okay
we don't need bumper stickers we don't
need lies and slogans and you know
campaign crap because that's what that
is the inflation rate month over month
went up it didn't go down and it
continues to go up now are they
dishonest at the white house or maybe
they're really just that stupid is there
anything that joe biden and i ask
yourself you know is there anything that
he has done well
think to yourself any one thing that you
can name or think of now he promised to
shut down kova 19. that turned out to be
a lie a big lie uh he promised that you
would get a vaccine if you got the
vaccine you'd never get covered we know
that's a lie he promised not to mandate
vaccines he'd never do it another lie he
promised not to raise taxes on the
middle class also a lie and remember
above all else he promised to unite the
country probably the biggest lie of all
instead of addressing the many crisis
affecting the u.s or bringing both sides
to together no bipartisanship whatsoever
joe is now busy literally smearing
slandering besmirching hundreds of
millions of americans and yesterday he
referred to conservatives and
republicans as domestic enemies he made
comparisons to jefferson davis the ku
klux klan and george wallace the same
george wallace who joe biden praised as
a senator well you remember that joe
well maybe you probably don't and of
course joe is just following orders from
his radical socialist base that is the
democratic party they want to completely
transform this country into their
socialist new green deal utopia they
want to maintain power in perpetuity
they love to call republicans fascists
and every other name
but they're the ones that are trying to
stack the supreme court not the
republicans they're the ones trying to
federalize all elections which is
unconstitutional they're the ones that
want to add let's see d.c and puerto
rico as u.s states why they think
they'll get x number of senators in
perpetuity and keep control and they are
the ones that are attempting to
eliminate right now the filibuster so
they can ram through their insane agenda
in the halls of congress with the
slimmest of majorities now today on the
senate floor tom cotton was brilliant he
read this impassioned speech actually
defending the filibuster i'll explain
take a look
constitutional scholars will tell us
that the reason we have these rules in
the senate
unlimited debate
two-thirds to change the rules
the idea that 60 have to close off
debate
is embodied in the spirit
and rule of the constitution
the bottom line is very simple
the ideologues in the senate
want to turn the founding fathers
what the founding fathers called the
cooling saucer of democracy into a
rubber stamp of dictatorship
those are powerful words
but they're not mine
every word of my speech today
was originally spoken
by our esteemed colleague
the senior senator from new york
chuck schumer
yeah we're going to be a banana republic
if we do this that's right when schumer
was in the minority party he defended
the filibuster tooth and nail said we'd
be a banana republic so also did joe
biden then a senator take a look
we should make no mistake
this nuclear option is ultimately an
example of the arrogance of power
it is a fundamental power grab
by
the majority party
propelled by its extreme right and
designed to change the reading of the
constitution
folks who want to see this change want
to eliminate one of the procedural
mechanisms
designed for the express purpose
of guaranteeing individual rights
and they also as a consequence would
undermine the protections of a minority
point of view
in the heat
of majority excess
what changed joe even more recently in
2019 and 2020 democrats they use the
filibuster
a whopping three over 300 times oh okay
they're against the filibuster now sadly
their thirst for power
knows no bounds that's the real threat
democrats have a major problem almost no
one approves of their platform or their
decrepit cognitively struggling career
politician that they put in the white
house that i doubt knows that today is
wednesday anyway here's another record
for joe according to quinnipiac look at
this
joe biden's approval rating is at an
all-time low
33
his approval rating among independents
is even lower 25 percent his poll
numbers are so bad that even democrats
want to avoid appearing with biden in
public for example yesterday stacey
abrams completely blew him off m.i.a she
had an important lunch reservation or
some other scheduling conflict she just
couldn't make it across town to meet
with the president and vice president of
the united states or as joe calls kamala
the president of the united states but
according to the chief propagandist jen
saki no one would ever avoid appearing
with joe biden really
he's the most beloved most competent
president in the history of the united
states
okay i don't know if it's an edible or
they're smoking something you decide
as the midterms approach there will be
some democrats but
plausibly who will want to stay away
from the president for for political
reasons what's his what's his response
to that
uh sort of uh
action
i think we're talking about a
hypothetical that doesn't yet exist
in reality joe and kamala are so toxic
that in the wall street journal
two lifelong democratic strategists this
is how bad this is getting they're now
floating a new candidate for 2024.
guess who
hillary clinton now when hillary clinton
frankly one of the most unlikable people
in the world seems like a better option
it's pretty bad so you know we will see
if
we get a rematch between trump and
hillary that would be interesting hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else